the Grammy goes to do a leap
I'm gonna let you first finish your
speech because I'm sure there are other
things you wanted to say I just I I just
I didn't really expect it and although
I'd like imagine that moment probably my
whole life I was petrified and I went up
up up on stage and I there were so many
people that I wanted to thank and you
know my friends and my family and my
label have been working so hard and my
team who you know they've done so much
for me and my friends back home and my
fans always my fans I know I thank them
tonight but I need to stress that again
because they've really given me this
opportunity and my band and my whole
team that makes me feel like a million
bucks every night honestly it's it's
just it really takes an army and I'm so
grateful to have the support that I do
and to be British and to have that
recognition it's just it just blows my
mind and to be here tonight it's just
it's so crazy and yeah I wish I thought
of all these things to say when I was up
there because I really I feel like there
are so many people that have done so
much for me that I just didn't have the
chance because my brain just went on
total meltdown of what is happening
right now that's okay but that's what
you also talked about the women this
year stepping up and making a difference
absolutely and and I I think that's so
important and it's such an honor to be
alongside so many amazing women that I
love and I look up to and it's so cool
to be on this journey with them and to
see so many female artists in the new
category and hopefully we get to see
more and more of that for many years to
come because it's really special you won
one of the toughest categories of the
night that's shock that moment when you
hear heard what goes through is it
electricity that goes through your body
electricity that goes through my body
honestly it was just I don't know I was
shaking like a leaf as you could tell
like I I've had it a little bit I've had
we have a tough time trying to get my
words out but I am beyond honoured and
ecstatic and grateful for this crazy
moment in my life that I I can never
replicate that feeling ever again
congratulations thanks for some
[Music]